you asleep over there I I kind of am all
right get it together Robert Redford
also in that you're representing for
everyone from No Strings Attached okay
question three what movie was a winner
of four Oscars four definitely four and
followed a pair of brothers one who
could count cards tell how many
toothpicks dropped from a box Kelly that
is what Kelly CL oh my God I am a shame
oh my God oh my
God I honestly did not think I was going
to do well this Natalie you can do this
okay okay I want you to just Center
yourself I want you to find your pride
and I want you to fight for that Pride
okay thank you thank you all right
question four what film featured a young
dancer in the New York City Ballet
slowly going Kelly
Clarkson so sorry Black
Swan just so wait
wait just so you know I have lost games
to my own songs so just so you know an
hathway just just annihilated me yeah on
since you've been gone yeah yeah I've
sng it once or twice all right a great
film Black Swan
[Music]
okay
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home